you open it doors all right the winner
is and the winner is and the Oscar goes
to the Oscar goes to and the Oscar goes
to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Academy governor's Kate amend and Roger
Ross Williams
I think good evening and welcome to our
Oscar event honoring the nominated films
in the documentary short and the
documentary future categories our fellow
governor Rory Kennedy is on location and
she can't be here tonight but she wants
the filmmakers to know that she loves
each and every one of your films and she
said your nominations make me proud to
be a documentary filmmaker and I second
that
congratulations and thank all of you for
being here tonight to honor these
extraordinary films and filmmakers this
year we're celebrating the 90th
anniversary of the Academy Awards but in
the early years of the Oscars there
weren't awards for documentaries
occasionally some nonfiction films did
win in the short subject category but it
wasn't until the 14th Academy Awards in
1942 that for the first time the Academy
gave special honorary awards to three
feature documentaries Churchill's Island
target for tonight and koukaon so
actually this is the 76th anniversary of
the dock of the Oscars for documentaries
however these films only received
certificates rather than Oscar
statuettes but koukin was not only the
first American documentary to be so
recognized it was also the first
co-produced by a woman the Chinese
American filmmaker and actress Li Ling I
however for some reason she was listed
in the credits as technical adviser and
the film was lost for decades but there
are some elements that have been found
and this fascinating story has been told
in the subject of a recent documentary
cuckoo finding kook on which I highly
recommend if you can see it but then in
the early years the from then on the
best documentary became an official
oscar-nominated
category and in those early years the
oscar-winning documentaries seemed
largely focused on world war 2 and were
produced by mostly government
institutions such as the US Army Signal
Corps the British military British
Ministry of Information and so forth but
that was then today our art form knows
no bounds and we're here tonight to
celebrate that by talking about the
powerful films that have been created by
our stellar nominated filmmakers so you
know so we actually have come a long way
since 1941
today documentaries you know they
challenge governments they don't support
them we change lives we change
perceptions we give voice to those who
society look past we're constantly
changing the perception of what a
documentary is we continue to break
barriers as a community by supporting
and encourage
women filmmakers and filmmakers of color
the films nominated today do all these
things often at great personal risk and
little financial gain our shorts take on
big subjects the opioid crisis in
America mass incarceration driving while
black in this country
art and mental illness elder abuse our
features illustrate a huge range of what
a documentary can be a David and Goliath
tale that shines the spotlight on the
hypocrisy of the financial banking
system in America brave heroes who pull
life from the rubble in one of the most
brutally bombed places on earth the
unfolding of widespread doping and
corruption schemes in Russia a deeply
personal story of injustice and systemic
racism
and an exuberant love letter to the
influence of images by giving power
through the stunning portraits of
everyday people together these nominated
films tell a bigger story of how
connected we are becoming as a community
in the dark world Oscar is not so white
I am not anymore I am we still have lots
of work to do but I can report here
today that we are the most diverse
branch in the Academy
Thanks
we tonight we have our first transgender
nominee and Yancy Ford know where you
are
we have our first Syrian nominee in
Ferris rod and ends and we have a long
overdue nomination from documentary
legend Steve James so you know I look
forward to the day when we won't have to
have firsts
or seconds or thirds where eventually it
will become completely unremarkable to
have people of color or different types
of stories I want to thank all the
filmmakers here today have worked so
hard to tell their stories and tell
their truths and I want to congratulate
everyone on their nomination
so we're going to start our program by
looking at some scenes from the shorts
nominees
Edith + Eddie Laura check away director
producer Thomas Lee right producer
beautiful place they comes a bird going
north I guess ya be able to see and see
what's out ya know I was so we're yeah
well they might be anything nighttime I
kind of words you anything well put it
this way I'm so thankful to live in this
world when we came here now we've been
here a long long time and we don't know
how much longer that we have so I say we
should live let me do the best meatball
falls in the water love is one of the
best treat everybody ready yes thank you
treat everybody right if you see
somebody that need help help them
we have to honor each other and I come
here today to honor the oldest cousin in
our family and I'd like for your
daughter Rebecca please bring them down
front here so that everyone can see
newlyweds Eddie and eat it
[Applause]
doing things to try to break up a
marriage or hinder imagine they got
married
god-honest night and we're on in this
one here today so we thank God for this
people come let's stand everybody give
him a good clap what did I love about
eating well she was kind and and
considerate and talking to me that they
come of the skin but the heart that's
what we decided where the heart is red I
believe
she needed him he'd need so God made her
and Mia what the Robin :
why we had been going to judge the
murder they tried to say it's not legal
they think they're glass down like
they're not coming where's down we ran
to life
I was called by my lawyer and told that
my sister may come and pick them up I
said we can't separate it from Eddie
Eddie does not want to go to Florida
he's never been on it clean and he's
saying that right now isn't the time for
him to try it now they don't want to
take Eddie and my sisters told me many
times that her husband is abusive
abusive abusive I think the objective is
to move mom separate mom and Eddie and
me and sell the house or rip the house
and put them into an institutional
situation to institutionalize them
I decided he's put it in God's hands and
heaven is a traffic jam on the 405 frank
stifle director-producer
nothing to her I'm not remembering
things in order for the last couple of
my months I've been having some pity
back pretty bad problems
I wasn't feeling too well on my old
medication and we talked to that
medication which really made things even
worse and I don't want to go back back
on it but I've been through several
different medications and with all kinds
of side effects and I was having some
hallucinations
I would wake up in the morning and I
would just hear all the towns of the
city
screaming in my ears I would hear
airplanes
children screaming punching holes and
terrible things happening to people and
I would see people stuck in peel green
black sea and I really thought it was
will this is a really hard and
depressing trying time but it's really
not nearly as bad as times as I've had
before and where I've ended up in the
hot pistol and suicidal times ago
I was to seven fold and that's when I
completely fell apart and had no
subpoena at all not any ability to write
or think words I just started to lose
control of my body I had had a nervous
breakdown
and I was hospitalized
Minda mental haha pissed it off the
doctor there said he don't worry we will
find the rock in your head so I was
terrified because I thought that there
was some gigantic tumour going on my
brain I really had a lot of trouble
finding woods if I saw a chair I knew
what it was but I didn't know the name
for it my friends made a list of words
for me and I could point to the words
and then it evolved into cutting up the
words and then eventually I built a box
inside of an old slide box
some were descriptive words some works
aware words which were necessary
and then some were just abstract ideas
I was very prolific with my drawing and
I think that I was telling more complete
stories maybe because I so desperately
was trying to communicate
I didn't on-and-off able to speak for
proximately ten times the rest of the
Sun in one 994 I was given shock
treatments
I was extremely suicidal and the
medication wasn't working nothing seemed
to be helping and I understood that
could be an auction and I'm aged my
doctor's - please try that
heroine Elaine macmillian Sheldon
director-producer Karen Sheldon producer
[Music]
[Music]
when you take an opiate it attaches to
certain receptors in the brain and it
basically suppresses your respiratory
system you stop breathing naloxone
actually knocks the opiate off that
receptor so they start breathing again
they've completely they woke up
immediately
you are the bone diggity
you're gonna save lives you know that
yeah it's a moral obligation to me I'm
an old medic I'm a nurse I'm a
firefighter I'm built to help people
[Music]
first responders in general don't treat
those suffering from addiction well they
haven't in the past and we're trying to
change that here in Huntington well look
at there there's my prince charming here
is our naloxone policy it's the city
policy so use your best judgment whether
you need to use it or wait for EMS and
just bag and that's how the policies
written it says you can so you're not
you're under obligation to provide BLS
which is basic life support which is
providing rescue breaths if you get
notification that EMS is going to be
awhile I'd go ahead and use it right one
box per truck there's there's two doses
in there I am number three goes on
Engine two and number four goes just put
it in the medic bag okay and there's
plenty that Health Department has plenty
so you know if you if you want to use it
feel free to go ahead two boxes in the
lock zone luenell oxen
I'm try to call anytime you have a safe
let me know immediately put it in the
run give me the run number any data that
I can use I'm not really sure what a
plateau is going to look like you know I
see this as a countrywide problem that
has the potential to bankrupt the
country you know we conservatively
estimated that Cavill county and we're
talking ninety six thousand people spent
probably about a hundred million dollars
in health care costs associated with IV
drug use in 2015 that's one small County
than one small state
I don't I can't even fathom what it's
going to look like when it plateaus but
I know it will be welcome
yes ma'am that wasn't overdose we're
clear returning copy one knife skills
Thomas Lennon director producer because
what a scoff ei said was you have these
five mother sauces and from those sauces
you can make any other sauce okay we
just talked about the base of it is
white stock all my fondest memories are
around the dinner table and I mean
that's what me and my mom did together
sauces tomato here when took over my
whole entire life my whole entire being
no I think I like this I've been to
prison once and in and out of County
countless times and I'd go to sleep and
pray not to wake up I'd be so mad so mad
so mad to be alive
[Music]
right there my apartment building
first floor knock right on the window
get a nickel back
I didn't think about at 14 and 15 and 16
that I would be that I would a mass I be
a drug dealer and be discouraged of
society and bring down homes and happy
families and people who who plans to do
something like that it just was
something to do and then it was
something that I did and then there was
something that I became good at it's a
tangled web we weave
[Music]
my official title was the Poitier in the
way that I remember it is is spelled as
if it's Poseidon the fish guy
[Music]
I would have never imagined to wrap fish
with potatoes okay you have fish and
french fries together but to encrust a
fish with potatoes it just blows my mind
think that thinking about it right now
[Music]
up at that we onion tomatoes what else
zucchini yellow squash olive oil so
spawn what does wrong you misunderstood
red commence what colors you use for the
detail in the pasta they have to cook
well and I'm going to teach him to cook
well okay what kind of cheese we use for
the certain number of to the fried goat
cheese goat cheese my god she's the
school what kind of meaning that we use
real warm no yes
what else
upon your breath Antonia tell visitor
motions turn motions
[Music]
that's a whole sermon dispatch because
the gears are red
the group does little better yeah that's
a little better now we're talking
alright try to make it like a football
[Music]
that's how you want it like this
[Music]
on $50 how much you can use on dollar in
dollars
[Applause]
they called the rib cage
[Music]
they brought up traffic stop
Kate Davis director David Brunner
producer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
Amy
I was pulled over
by an officer
I was asked sitting back in my car I
complied I did what he asked me to do
and I was sitting in my car
and I'm just like oh my god
I don't know why but I don't trust you
[Music]
now I dunno why I did not trust
can the filmmakers please come up
[Applause]
and you have assigned seats that's why I
love documentaries every one of those
films it's just so powerful why don't we
just go down everybody introduce
yourself so you'll know who's who and
who's with with which film Tom right
producer Edith and Eddie Laura check
Roey
director producer Edith and Eddie Frank
stifle heaven is a traffic jam on the
405
Elaine Macmillan Sheldon director
producer heroine Curran Sheldon producer
and director of photography of heroine
Thomas Lennon knife skills Kate Davis
director traffic stop David Holub runner
producer traffic stop thank you
you know I I feel such a personal
connection to all the people in your
films you know you bring them there's an
intimacy there's a connection that just
jumps off the screen and I once heard al
Maysles say I'm paraphrasing but he said
something to the effect we make
documentaries to make new friends and I
just wonder if that resonates for for
you on everybody
address that question well personally
experiencing the company of all these
filmmakers has been a really gratifying
thing because we have a lot of respect I
think in collegiality in this category
and very grateful to have made the
acquaintance of these really fine
filmmakers absolutely I agree with Al
and I just feel so enriched by getting
to know Edith and Eddie and their loved
ones and I feel like you know each film
that I've made so far I sort of walk in
one person and walk out a much deeper
richer person so absolutely I I speak to
too many more often that I speak to my
kids leader I speak to her every day and
I think you know I mean there are people
who do this well I'm not one of them I
you know I need to fall in love with the
people and I'm making a film that I
can't sort of operate on cynicism and so
it is an act of love and it is an act of
friendship and and community yeah and
did the three women in our film I mean
the thing about any documentary making
any documentary I don't necessarily have
to agree with the people in filming I
don't have to be their best friend but I
certainly respect their point of view
and luckily these three women are just
awesome women and as well as people on
the ground doing incredible things so I
am happy to call them friends in a very
special way yeah and I would just add to
that I mean we we make documentaries and
make new friends we also make
documentaries to learn
from the people that we interact with
everyone here up on this stage everyone
who makes documentaries but also the
three women in our film I believe has
made me knowing them has made me a more
compassionate and kinder and nicer human
being hopefully and you know it's just
nice to learn that through the process
of creating film I think I have agree
with Al mezzos which is to say that
there is a an incredible intimacy that
happens when you connect with a
documentary subject and you have to on
some level I think fall in love with
them and also then the process of
getting a story I find creates a kind of
strange kind of transference where I'm
like loving the person whether I might
or might not in regular life I am in
that work but at the same time you know
we're professionals and I don't I don't
presume to speak for Frank you know I've
had that argument before in the sense of
you know for him friendship and
filmmaking or one in the same for me
French friendship is part of filmmaking
but then there's also this tricky moment
where my priority becomes not the
friendship but the film and in that
process I can feel myself distancing
myself and prioritizing something else
there's a famous sentence by Janet
Malcolm where she said you know every
act of journalism is an act of betrayal
and I think that's an overstatement but
there is a process of separation and
that that becomes very tricky because
you really love that person but you love
your film more than you love that person
and and so that that and sometimes that
gets you into into complicated ethical
territory I'm not not speaking
personally of course I've never
committed anything no no of course not
I'm talking about other people well I
mean every film is different and
sometimes the issues to me drive the
relationship more than the relationship
and sometimes not with traffic stop I
feel like it was one of those rare films
of the bunch that I've done where I
really just
inspired by our subject and her courage
to stand up to the cops and later on
question them and it wasn't easy for her
to be in the film and and at all because
she had suffered from PTSD so so much
and so in a way I feel like I've lived
through although were friends I think as
something deeper is going on that
involves me feeling really humbled in
her presence and that gets back to the
learning really truly learning from
people who are facing crises and trauma
and hardships that I have not myself and
and it's it's like friendship the
relationship you develop with your
subjects but it's maybe a little bit
more complicated because it's it is sort
of a one-sided relationship it's that
transference thing you're at you're
saying tell me more about yourself tell
me more oh that's fascinating and by the
time the interview was done they may be
crying and they they really care about
you but they really don't know you and
it's a very strange experience at the
best of times you do become friends and
it has happened but it doesn't happen
every time certainly not why I went into
filmmaking but it was a great fringe
benefit when it works out and it did
with traffic stop Katie I agree that was
that was a fantastic experience and you
know when I treasure great thank you
well let's talk about Edith and Eddie so
the film starts out so fun they're
dancing they're exercising they're doing
their morning routine I mean what point
is that the film that you started out to
make and what point did it take a turn
yeah it is I set out to make a film
about newlyweds who had gotten married
at age 95 and 96 and just wanted to know
what it would be like to find love at
that time in your life so I thought it
would be a short portrait much like what
you see in the first several minutes of
films just I'm enjoying their time
together and going to church and having
a new reason to wake up in the morning
and then we find out that there's a
disagreement among ITA's daughters about
what's best for their mom and so it
takes a really sharp turn into you know
something completely unexpected when the
couple's in danger of being torn apart
and you must have been so angry and
frustrated as I mean at the situation
yeah absolutely and you know there was I
think that you know you set out on this
adventure as a filmmaker to just if
you're following people's lives in real
time then you don't know what twists and
turns are gonna come and so we do just
try to stay centered in that and the
work that we're there to do and at the
same time our hearts are really bleeding
and still bleeding yeah Thomas I know
that you edited a book the family guide
to preventing elder abuse would you talk
a little bit about that issue and are
you using this film as outreach oh sure
yes we really hope that this film has
life beyond the present moment and this
issue is such an important and emergent
one I had just lost my father prior to
meeting Laura and saw the initial
footage that she had shot and was very
very moved for very personal reasons and
just knew that there was a reason that
we had met and and then we've been doing
this for the last couple of years
together and so that book was being
edited I had several experts on the
subject contribute chapters and and and
so there's an educated element to this
but it all begins with
the Edith and Eddie themselves and their
way of expressing their need for
autonomy their way of expressing love
for one another and we both felt very
strongly that we had to preserve their
dignity and the telling of the story and
that that was one of their strongest
messages really it's heartbreaking but
it's so powerful so Frank well Mindy is
compelling from the moment we see her
and her art did you know her art first
was how were you introduced to Mindy
my wife is an artist and works in that
same studio and so my first introduction
was BJ coming home and talking about
this woman who who makes this incredible
art in the back of the studio and
doesn't speak to anybody and over time
they would have coffee at the end of the
day and I think there was a group show
and I saw the work for the first time
and just was astounded and then we found
ourselves sort of it art shows together
and and I was curious I mean there's not
one minute of that film that I knew
about there's nothing I knew nothing
about her illnesses I knew nothing about
her family by the way anybody want to
meet Mindy she's right over there
[Applause]
so so I just became curious I didn't
know you know I just wanted to know
where that art came from
why was she the way she was and it was
you know I had no clue as to what this
story was and didn't for the longest
time and so it would just describe this
to to a student the other day I said
it's religion you you know there's no
evidence that there's a film there just
keep on showing you know I probably a
good bit of evidence that there isn't
you know you just keep on showing up as
if there might be and and so you know a
story emerged but it took a long long
time clearly she trusted you and was
open to you yeah I mean there were six
interviews with Mindy and you know and
the interviews got deeper and deeper and
deeper and there were three interviews
with her mother that that also got
deeper and then you know it just you
know I interviewed everybody in that
studio never used any of that footage
the you know the ratio of footage used
to footage shot is just ridiculous and
and that's what happens when you don't
you know when you you don't really know
where the film is and the film will come
together at some point might you know I
made a film earlier than that where I
you know I knew exactly what the film
was so this was just a matter of just
showing up and and believing that there
was a cogent story that would come
together
and her art is so powerful yeah you know
your film
we only saw one there one of your
subjects they're three strong women
did you set out to feature women only or
was it more just to look at the problem
yeah we live like 40 minutes away from
Huntington and Charleston West Virginia
so we were looking for a story about the
solutions that were happening on the
ground it's a story that's you know one
that's been haunting us for a while as
journalists and documentarians living in
the state you know we've I've had a lot
of classmates too many familiar
obituaries and mug shots so to say that
and so we were just looking for what are
people doing you know what is happening
and it turned out that these three women
were really the standouts you know we
started by interviewing the mayor's Drug
Control Policy Board and once we
interviewed generator on that it's kind
of just we stopped on the board and Dan
took us in a fire truck for you know the
first several days and introduced us to
all of her friends we jokingly called
this film Jane and her friends for a
while and it you know Jan was very easy
to warm up to she's a person that will
hug you the first time she meets you and
but the other two women it really took a
lot of relationship building what they
do is working with populations that they
don't want to exploit and you know
reveal in any way that's harmful and so
um I wouldn't say we necessarily set out
to document women but the women were who
were the people we were drawn to that
what they were doing on the ground
there's certainly men on the ground
doing great things - hence the title
well and the Center for Investigative
Reporting did their glass breaker
initiative was funding short films about
women making change and so we had shot
this footage
and really had no place for it and had
no funding for it and that call-out came
about six months after we had shot some
of the preliminary footage and we were
able to find the first round of funding
through them so that's sort of like the
problem is it's called the overdose
capital of America but the media has
treated Huntington it's like an abusive
partner relationship I mean people have
been dropping into Huntington because
they've been so transparent about their
overdose numbers they have an app that
has live data they've been so
transparent to try to get help because
they have no resources but in turn in
turn a lot of media has come in and said
some really non true potentially non
true things but the overdose rate is 10
times the national average so it could
be easily called the overdose capital so
yeah I mean friends from high school in
middle school yeah it's it's I mean I
grew up in a we're both from West
Virginia we grew up in different parts
of the state but the part that I grew up
in is essentially just coal mining
communities and those communities small
pharmacies were flooded with you know
Kermit West Virginia got 9 million pills
over two years to one pharmacy and it's
a town of three hundred and seventy two
so that was sort of the backdrop of my
growing up and now it's heroin and
fentanyl encouragement Kevin you're the
cinematographer and producer yeah I'm
producer right so talk about going on
those ride alongs yeah we didn't really
want to do it to be honest I think you
know Elaine that both wanted to show a
story of hope a story of inspiration and
you know a lot of the media that comes
into Huntington is very focused on sort
of the the user sort of the
glorification of drug usage in a way and
so we really want to focus on these
three women who are who are making
change and you're helping those in need
but the same time we knew we had to show
the issue in order to get across the
point of you know what they're facing
and
sort of what they need to overcome and a
lot of ways I mean it's it's it's a
pretty terrible experience in a lot of
ways because you are I mean your first
goal is just not getting away you know
they're these are first responders doing
their job and and they're saving a life
and so it's you know make sure that your
lights it's just the two of us you know
one camera kind of hunker down into your
shoulder and you just try to stay out of
the way but I mean you're seeing someone
who's potentially it's the lowest part
of their life and you know is is you
know if the EMS gets there three minutes
later that they're probably going to die
so you know you're seeing someone on
that Burge and then sort of snap out of
it and it's it's a pretty harrowing
experience in a lot of ways but you know
if you we just sort of focused on the
women focused on Jan focus on the first
responders doing their job and you know
they sort of give you that uplift to to
kind of live in that situation well it's
very powerful to be that close but it
also speaks to the idea that one person
can make a difference these women are
definitely yeah I mean Jan's the first
female fire chief in West Virginia so
she has a position to get up every
morning and serve her community and the
judge patricia Keller's the drug court
judge family court judge but initial
Freeman the third one is she's a single
mom real estate agent who has taken upon
herself to help women working in the sex
trade for their drug addiction and so
she's she's everyone in this room you
know she is a person that has found the
time made the time and the love to help
people suffering in her community so
she's in many ways I think a great
example of you know people always feel -
when a problem so large they feel like
they have no control over it and they
often just run away from it but all
three of these women go right towards it
and they all show that you can have
impact so thank you
Thomas knife skills this is such an
incredible beautiful film the food
fantastic but it's all beautifully shot
I shot it yes and took sound and that's
no way to make a film but it's the way I
did it well I don't know I just think
the premise of this restaurant is so
preposterous and we didn't we didn't see
Brandon who's the founder of the
restaurant yeah it's this is a person I
met completely by chance I did not have
any background in criminal justice I I
didn't have a a position staked out on
on any of these issues I was just your
average newspaper reader in terms of
that that stuff but I met this odd guy
in his 30s very intense had a pretty
gold-plated resume as a restaurateur had
worked at trotters in Chicago which is
kind of the premier restaurant in
Chicago had worked at chanterelle which
was one of the top four or five
restaurants in New York and he'd also
even though he did not speak a word of
French he'd somehow managed to spend six
months working in a French restaurant
God knows how that worked but but anyway
but he had had brushes with the law as a
young man and he had just decided that
this was something he was gonna do the
thing he knew how to do was run
restaurants and he was gonna run a
restaurant and almost everyone but the
except with the exception of two people
in the restaurant were all people who
were recently released from prison most
of whom had no cooking experience at all
and my good fortune was that I got to
meet him just when he was signing the
lease and getting ready to do this and I
just knew we met over a meal a mutual
friend and I knew before we'd finished
the first course that this was a film
and and so started coming out there and
like you I had to stay out of the way
the stakes were
it's high but the but the pots are very
hot and the kitchen was very small and
so I just started hanging out and and I
think that I don't think ignorant is
ever a virtue in making a film but I do
think the fact that I didn't really come
to it with any background with no
message that no preconception I think
that was kind of an asset because I just
hung out and watched and and then sort
of went through certain stages of
education that I think the average
person would go through my first thought
when I went out there is like god is
gonna have these guys with like you know
lots of tattoos and bulging muscles and
you know and that was essentially
completely wrong and so I said I had to
work my way through that and then I came
to be so attached to these folks that it
was just like wow gosh all they needed
was the second chance it isn't this
great
isn't this peachy and then one after
another the people I was following
started getting into trouble and then I
started reading and then I understood
that that's in fact the road to recovery
is a bumpy one for people coming out of
prison and that in fact what I was
finding was very representative but I
didn't know that so I just had to sort
of take a deep gulp and just say let me
keep filming I don't want to make a film
that says never hire anybody who said
prison that's not what I said I have to
do but if there are problems that are
associated with hiring people who are
just out of prison I let me trust the
story and keep filming and I think in
the end that worked itself out but that
was that was sort of the terrifying
moment which was oh my goodness
everyone almost every character I'm
following is shooting themselves in the
foot in one way or another what the hell
am I doing here what what is his story
I'm telling and then it took care of
itself it's because you just you just
dig deeper and you just keep filming and
you trust that the material will speak
in a way
did I ask how the restaurant is doing
thriving thriving and by the way such as
the power of a nomination that now
there's like they were doing fine before
they were you know when we finished but
now it's like four people stacked at the
bar you know every night and like
they're having a special Oscar night
party I mean that you know that and and
Brandon is you know I mean he's like the
biggest deal in Cleveland since LeBron
James possibly bigger it is just
astonishing the power of this bare
buttocks statue over there it's just
staggering
Betty Davis's husband thank you so
traffic stop devastating film and
powerful because of Breann said how you
say her name brown yes yeah yeah how did
you find her there was a little clip of
her getting tossed around by the Austin
police that went viral shortly after her
arrest and we you know worked closely
with with HBO right away we all felt
this could be a story depending on who
she turned out to be in person and she
didn't jump at it as I said she was
really suffering she was it for a year
basically stayed under her covers and
couldn't teach and and then it was sort
of a slow emergence and she took this as
an opportunity to in a sense turned
something good out of a terrible
situation where she felt you'll if you
see the film it's it really suggests
that her feeling of being oppressed
stemmed from childhood which makes sense
and so
racism is a is just a theme throughout
the film that culminates in this
collision with the police and so that's
you know we've met with her and we had
just sort of stuff each other out and
see if it just felt right well we didn't
expect and which is really a uplifting
part of the film is that she's
incredible teacher she's a teacher I
wish I had you know the second grade
teacher that's extraordinary um and
she's a dancer and I had to cut out the
singing because she's too freaking good
at everything so that would be too much
so um you know he you know if it happens
to her she had a clean record then I
think I'm hoping that the film will help
a general audience realize it could
happen to anybody
you know if you don't look right
according to you know primarily white
law enforcement it's it's it's a very
scary situation
which much of the population myself
included is is fairly you know it can be
quite oblivious to so I'm hoping we can
you know put ourselves a little bit in a
Brianna's shoes she lived to tell the
story and I'm happy to say you know the
film process was very therapeutic for
her she will have a gown on Sunday night
but it wasn't yeah but you know it
wasn't clear when we went down much as
we loved her and thought she was
charming and finding out she had no
criminal background and was this
wonderful teacher was great but when we
turned the camera on her it was it was
really a fascinating experience because
she just started crying and I don't mean
crying a little bit but crying buckets
and for the whole interview and it's one
thing you've got a moment when someone
breaks down in the interview it's it's
it's it's it can be really powerful but
she cried the whole time and so we came
back from this first shoot going like
she's great but we can't use anything
she's crying all the time and and so we
eventually came back and and she you
haven't seen the interview there's not
much interview material that of this
little clip we had but she's wonderful
in poise and self reflective and I later
learned only
eight months later from her boyfriend
but this was a pivotal moment for her to
be interviewed by us apparently she had
really never spoken about this in depth
before and so the first interview he did
you know we joke you know sent him up
Varitek right we joke about cinema
therapy and this really was her
unburdening herself it was by no means
clear that we had a film in case we just
didn't know she could she could actually
talk about it and even now it's still a
little tough for her yeah
well what I love juxtaposing the dashcam
video with her life she is you see what
a great teacher she is and just you know
it's just such a wonderful vibrant human
being so it's interesting to learn that
it took a while to really capture that
but you did she's coming on Sunday she's
not here tonight is she's coming on
Sunday she's thrilled she's gonna be on
the red carpet she's gorgeous
[Music]
yeah she was fabulous intercutting
really was the heart one of the beauties
of making a short film is it it forces
you to be almost a little high cool
about it be more poetic because you
don't have the you know the cinematic
real estate to tell every little detail
and you know to it we did all these hard
cuts between the dashcam footage and
then the beauty of her private life and
it was that it's what you know cinema
can do sometimes that those hard slam
cuts that force you to feel the
juxtaposition between two things and and
it I hope brought brought up I hope it
brought brought out and brings home you
know the kind of violence that it did
very very powerful as we're all your
films so thank you all give everybody a
big round of applause
I'm gonna invite Roger of musical chairs
thank you all thank you
we're films here
you
you're in for a treat we are about to
see the clips for the nominated features
abacus small enough to jail Steve James
director mark Benton producer Julie
Goldman producer
and it's a humiliation
[Music]
as a humiliation vote for me
and that's where I saw incompetence
combined with arrogance my deputy bureau
chief he's always so inspirational and
he would always refer to the
inscriptions outside 100 Center Street
about having faith in justice but I
don't I don't believe that anymore I
decided to leave the DA's office it
really angered the Chinese community but
if so what they're not going to decide
an election for Vince this is the
Association where my great-grandfather
was a grandfather my my dad back in the
days with the exclusion act people do
not have rights this is where they would
all come family associations like this
one of the only place where they felt
welcome like mr. song what drives me is
the sense of community okay okay hey
give it up this case is about an attack
on our community we're easy prey I think
that's what's going on people have
reason to be fearful of authority on
what can happen to them
you know the retribution the years of
oppression that happened from the street
vendors from the small businesses from
people just writing tickets because they
can and those are sunshine it sank it
had no principal oh man awoke you - are
you we are no taller to talk at all
how much honey them come on move along
Johanna go go away hey come to go
walking chip ha Sybok Tomasi gonna make
all your change
come on what do you see male yo quit if
I say only a conical : vanilla matanda
na de agua : s which appeals didn't our
lower dick you are you
it's more than just Africa savings bank
being clear
it's about exonerating our entire
community
no matter what we do be at the little
guy selling vegetables or a bank that's
doing business I told mr. song I'm glad
to pick on you because you're fighter
Cyrus man's just felt this is easier to
attack especially it's a family bank but
he doesn't realize tom is not easy to be
pushed around
and my girls they're tough smart capable
women so courageous
although this is David versus Goliath
David bean advocates Federal Savings
Bank has a slingshot and that is you
know their whole family of lawyers I was
gonna be able to fight this
they're almost gleeful they're like
we're gonna have her day in court now
we're actually gonna L to show that they
were wrong they made a decision that
they were not going to plead guilty to
something that they didn't feel the bank
was guilty of that is a courageous
choice and it's an expensive choice the
DA's office has hundreds of lawyers and
took five years to do their grand jury
investigations and it is a daunting task
to fight the government faces places
honest Barda writer-director junior
writer director Rosalie varta producer
hello not posey cetera papa hey Emily :
so the container like breezy Anya's
visage Cebu may come up in from the
booth young voice a mad no Whoville
River Hospital ooh
yes a Masucci Hawaii silver Ciera
[Laughter]
let the time portavoz para at Ocean oh
yeah are you where they got to put us it
visually tell me I do remember we're not
gonna become sorry some say puffy
yeah with the seriously that's it yeah
so the traffic lizard you disagrees when
you come to our constituents but with
him come Zach he haunts doesn't want
them but he says dull Helena
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
- totem we move - you see Preta suppose
a i'll enter here the lock poker
I guess k7 d 3c house on team under
liberty stroking on the towel say karma
sig home
Champa Champa daughter in white sir
Alessa - are you Neela no trabajas joy
Jarvis on the dominator see beyond
Sophie please here also
God loves you don't she fell
supposed to survive need to kill you I
don't use it as a discrete said what is
it is a fun night speaking of a
crystalline order cooler for ages about
posters they per strata conference set
on plication to terms of prison confetti
levels on a vampire by the decree shaky
existed at some confirm a me papal
newton-john Lavoie Papa's case on trail
Wham
mr. Fox's on the fan wazoo Icarus Brian
Fogle writer director producer Dan Cogan
producer do you know where 84 days away
to the Summer Games in Rio de Janeiro in
Brazil until now there's only really
been hard evidence about athletics but
this is now pointing the finger and a
whole range of sports
as you guys all know there's a
Department of Justice investigation
going
so Gregory it's been advised by his
lawyers he should not be here for
security reasons I worked with Gregory
over about six months to compile record
of what happened in Russia this is the
spreadsheet of every single athlete that
was on the state-mandated protocol what
every single athlete was taking in
London including their sample numbers in
collection when Christian goes back and
test these samples correctly she will
basically find them all positive and we
have all their protocols before the
London Games we have the same for
Beijing and this outlines is how Russia
was collecting thousands and thousands
of clean samples for swai so sodium
chloride is added to the sample to
increase specific gravity so many of
these samples are gonna have a hundred
times the sodium content that should be
in somebody's urine let me make sure I
understand they were taking to be to be
open secretly yes
no it means yes yes both the Olympic and
the Paralympic Games they swapped urine
Vancouver was really the impetus for the
urine swapping operation too they only
won a handful of metals and to see to it
that that didn't happen again
it's so true terms of time sensitive
London is more sensitive in this and
that these athletes are going to the
next Rio game this goes all the way back
to 1968 there never was anti doping in
Russia
period ever across all summer sports
every sport any story who's a scientist
I am happy to have been in Sochi and to
everything we gave credibility to the
lab do you think that I feel good today
do you think that the athletes who were
chief did feel good you know and it's
angry as you guys might be I think the
one thing Gregory risked his life and is
risking his life to do this he left his
wife behind
he left his children behind he left all
of his belongings behind all of his
financial security behind we're here to
get everything out
dear mr. Fogle and dr. a chenkov the IOC
has full confidence in the authority of
Professor Richard McClaren their
respects his judgment to ensure
comprehensive inquiry we will act
swiftly to take the necessary measures
Sincerely Yours Thomas Bach
president huge McClaren
these PLM SP orders are the actually
orders like Capernaum is ordering
reordering the lab this matter
yes newborn office is ordering this
ordering ordering Gregory there's
there's emails like explicitly about
soccer players
there's emails explicitly of you know
the weight lifters and that essentially
were of rowers swimmers or Gregory had
found the positive profile in the bank
[Music]
okay last men and Aleppo Farris fired
director Kareem a bead producer sir
enstein yes person producer I would love
them I don't
turkey salon for the recipe said miss
antibody mr. Woodhouse Auto no net house
for immediate DNA us both Anita Boyer
nephew a female tomato ally Turkey Egypt
soon as a severe I'm sure whatever shoot
any man without soap in front of all and
issue a key for college about unity and
I will claim they're like me powerful
would with them Ruby Bertram Melanie's
and the ball Danny without him in
ecology and I have come to her
was always there
wish me I no matter what I think no
little because a little $11 therapy and
it was how many so much only meant
exactly mobile phone
so I always have I'm a miss baby this
fella anyway [ __ ] president Matlock
that I was loving them what am i myself
am a civil remedy be fluid with the
turkey let me tell her he know a turkey
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
strong island yen's for director
producer Jocelyn Barnes producer what
flashed into my mind just now was the
room that we were waiting in the ad a
came in and called me in to testify I
walk in I sit down I look around the
room I see nobody who looks like me no
person of color
[Music]
they were sitting in an area like a
theater elevated seats there must have
been 20-something people there one
person was reading a book
another lady was reading a magazine
there was a conversation going on
my feelings were when I sat in that
chair was they don't care about what I
have to say they really don't they
weren't paying attention
they weren't okay and I became very
angry with myself because at one point I
began to pry and I hated that moment
because I felt that you know they were
going to say here is another black woman
who didn't do her job with her child and
now she wants us to make somebody pay
that's how I felt when your father came
back he said to me don't expect anything
because it's it ain't gonna happen and
how did you find out what they just they
came here who came here one a DA and a
detective
and what did they tell you they didn't
indict they returned no true bill that
was it I'm sorry
what happened after that I opened the
door and said thank you for coming and I
will be very honest with you we make
door closed I collapsed
please welcome to this stage the
filmmaking teams of the documentary
features
[Applause]
it's sobering watching those clips so
let's start by let's just go down the
line so we know who everyone is and say
your name and what you did on your film
Steve James director abacus mark mitten
producer abacus julie goldman producer
abacus and yes about that cool director
of mrs. Grayson Brian Ferrill director
Icarus dan Cogan producer Icarus fiafia
director of last minute a typo I'm sorry
yes person and one of the producers of
last men in a level
I'm Nancy Ford director of strong island
I'm Jocelyn Barnes producer and strong
woman
great um well Steve you're up first so
you know this is a film about you know
justice but it's also a film about
really strong women and the song women I
think they're here tonight
[Applause]
when you met these ladies did you know
you hit documentary gold yes I mean when
we went to first film we found out very
quickly that we were not going to be
able to film in the courtroom we found
out that we weren't going to be able to
film the prosecution's folks at all
their side of it we even found out we
weren't gonna be able to film the song's
defense lawyers which really shocked us
cuz defense lawyers like want to be
stars at movies generally but not these
guys
so we basically only had access in
quotes to the song family outside the
courtroom but they were so compelling
principled courageous funny that it was
like that's the center of our movie
anyway this is some should do stand up
she / sure she is so funny
yes the best comic timing of any subject
I've been involved with absolutely mark
you um you found the story you tell me
how how that came about and how did you
sort of bring it to Steve it was an
unsung story he should not do stand-up
yeah yeah you should not just that I
need lessons for missus sighs what they
said I had known the songs for almost a
decade and they revealed to me that they
were going to be indicted for mortgage
fraud and I was both perplexed and then
outraged when I found out that they were
the only bank that was going to be
indicted for mortgage fraud as part of
the 2008 financial crisis and what was
even more shocking was that it really
was an unsung story because the
mainstream media had not picked up on it
the Chinese American press covered it
every day but none of the mainstream
press did so at that point I felt there
was a story that certainly needed to be
told because it was a cautionary tale
and it's about the daughters the strong
daughters protecting the legacy of their
father so I reached out also here mr.
songs here sorry mr. song so I reached
out to Steve and Steve and I had worked
together on life itself and I said I
think there's something here but yeah I
want your opinion and as he already said
he came to New York and after a few days
he said there's definitely something
here so you guys are based in Chicago
you know famous sort of Chicago
filmmakers and most of your stories take
place in Chicago and but you worked with
Julie in New York and how did that work
Julie how did that really and they deign
to come to New York to make a film which
was quite shocking only the songs could
draw them there knowing to work with you
so what happened is that we really kind
of brought the team in that would be
doing the day-to-day filming and and you
guys really came back and forth quite a
bit to film but we had on the ground
like if we needed to capture something
we had our DP Tom Bergman who you know
well and our field producer Sean line
srap so that's like art you know we're
based in Brooklyn and it was our team
and at motto that was making sure that
if anything emergent happened we would
be capturing it or start to capture it
before you could get there especially
when there's a trial and there's a
verdict and you're you know kind of on
tenterhooks so how long is this going to
take and so we worked that way through
production and yes so when we talked at
the at the governors awards she received
the Governor's Award a Lifetime
Achievement Governor's Award this
I talked to you and you said there's so
many more important films and and you I
told you you were definitely gonna be
nominated because you made such a
special heartfelt film that really
touches people's hearts and you give
voice in this film to people who don't
have a voice to the workers to farmers
tell me how you came to jr. and his work
and why did you decide you know you
could do whatever you want but why did
you decide to work with J or J has
already worked in the direction that I
like you know he had a project called
inside out in when we feel magical truck
to many places and have people but you
know paced their own images together
cream creating links with images make
them big so it's exactly what I like to
do as documentaries so when my daughter
said how come you don't know each other
say no no so she said let's meet we met
and the day after we decided to do
something because it was obvious that
our ideas about what we can do with
people how we can represent them are the
same in the same direction and then we
decided to do the two in front to and
meet people as you noticed
simple people with no power so that we
could just make you audience meet these
people we felt we'd go between but also
we got along very well we our job our
relationship
it became slightly a part of the
documentary but mostly it's the people
we we involve you'll see in the sequence
you show here we got these these work to
be involved in the project not only
question and answer
they like the project and they help us
doing all the work that we couldn't do
with the containers it's like we wanted
people not only to enter in the
documentary but to be part of the design
of creation imagination makes things be
slightly different and jaian and I am
sorry is not here but it's not here
but we work together and we agree
totally that especially I am a feminist
so I've got them to work on making the
women be bigger than usual
and but it is true that it's you know
they were not allowed to come to that
part of the of the rubber so not only we
make them come but we made them big and
it became as he said which I love the
most is we pushed a little depression
the cliche that's what is good when when
I film a documentary the meeting the
what you know what we said what we
discussed make people change slightly
the same way which and and we learn
about what we feel yeah so where is
junior is that the says our awards say
where's Junior is in Paris and it
couldn't come that he Quinn come he's
coming into this and as you know when
I'm not with him he has a little bit
photo of me on a board a little photo he
has a life-size cutout that he he bought
to the nominees lunch and carried that
that that was such a tip because you
know it's beautiful what's happening but
for us being invited in Pascal and is is
a trip you know and we are joys more
than I'm not in the competition feeling
at all we are enjoying the fact you
having fun
great
so Brian you used to be a stand-up
comedian you have a background in
theater documentaries aren't normally
very funny how did you translate those
skills to making documentaries first of
all what an amazing honor to be up here
with all of you and so many of my
incredible film team are here in the
audience tonight that are I couldn't be
here without I just wanted to say that
before I answered your question
you know III guess I come from a
creative background and a background of
how of how to tell a story and also kind
of than when I set my mind to something
I just push and push until I see it
through and for this you know as I as I
when I started out I I couldn't have
imagined where it was gonna go to but
once I was in it I never saw a way out
of it Hey
I just kept going and going and going
much as we would have liked one
sometimes yeah
and so you know I think you know if I go
way back
I mean I was doing stand-up comedy 20
years ago but you know when you're doing
stand-up comedy you get up there and the
joke bombs and then you just got to keep
going and sometimes it gets really bad
and you just want to get off stage and
you're like okay I'm gonna push through
and and that was my experience through
life and as I set out to make this film
I had raised a little bit of money and I
wasn't gonna let myself down and I
didn't want to let this friend of mine
who had invested in me down and then Dan
Cogan and impact partners came into it
and I didn't want to let them down and
then I didn't want to let Gregory were
chenkov down so through it all it just
became this kind of epic journey of
three and a half years of wanting to see
to it that Gregory and
this story that that he was driving and
his desire to bring forward this truth
and my team that had surrounded this
project that we're all working so hard
to protect Gregory to do everything that
we could so that this truth could come
forward and through these two elements
and through having an incredible
creative team we persevered and and here
we are
tell us what tell us where Gregory is
now and well I guess you can't tell us
what Gregory is but who's planning to
bring a cutout of Gregory to the Oscar
nominee lunch and then jr. upstaged me
we thought the bear adjusted version
might be too much you know
things things are very serious for
Gregory I don't know where he is I
haven't been able to speak or have
contact with him for a very long time
he's in protective custody of United
States he's in an unknown location he's
under 24-hour protection and Putin has
formally asked the United States to
extradite him there are criminal charges
that he would spend his life in jail or
face execution in Russia and he is
considered by most authorities to be the
single biggest enemy of the Russian
state and is being hunted so it's
incredibly serious and he's been away
from his family for two years I don't
see an end in sight and the more tragic
thing about it is that we're learning in
this world in this society that telling
the truth doesn't necessarily set you
free and not only does it not set you
free in the case of Gregory he's gonna
have a mark on his back for the rest of
his life
and we learned yesterday that the
Olympics have lifted this ban on Russia
and yet they never even
initiative to begin with the ban was all
[ __ ] they had allowed a hundred and
sixty Russian athletes into the games
two of them were caught for doping
Russia's never even confessed to any of
this regardless of what is in the film
and then two investigations afterwards
proven that everything is true and and
it makes you kind of wonder what is the
point and being so brave to tell the
truth when the outcome is this and me
standing on this stage we're sitting on
this stage is just an honor to Gregory
and and being able to shine a spotlight
on something that is incredibly serious
and affecting our democracy and
democracies around the world
[Applause]
and the brave man very brave man dan
you're normally an EP many many many
films and you know too many to count
that you see peed why did you sort of
you know decide to jump in and produce
this film
somebody had to you know we came into
this film when Brian was making a film
about him doping himself and I love that
idea because it was sneaky it was
muckraking I love the idea of watching
some you know we hear about doping in
sports all the time but we never see it
because it's supposed to be secret and
so I love the idea thing I should be
able to watch someone do this and see
the effects on them and then see if they
could actually get through the system
looking clean and I thought it was a
brilliant idea that Brian had and I was
excited about doing it and so we had
impact partners went ahead and did it
and then when things changed when
Gregory was outed this guy who was
helping him dope who was out as the
center of the Russian doping conspiracy
and he called Brian up and said I need
to come to the LA now I need to escape
everything changed and all of a sudden
we were dealing not just with the making
of a film but with criminal lawyers with
immigration lawyers with finding him
security with keeping the production
secure from Russian hacking and so we
had a whole set of challenges you're not
normally dealing with with a film and it
was Brian and I doing it and so I just I
really didn't have a choice I just threw
myself in full-time to producing it with
him and that's how we did it for the
next two years I am strangely in the
film and if you if you want to see an
accurate picture of a miserable producer
and watch them
there's there's a moment where we're
meeting with a lawyer of his who was not
very good and and we're listening to the
terrible choices we have to choose among
and I just could not look more miserable
and it's an accurate portrayal preparing
a set of outtakes called Dan Cogan
miserable producer first you
you made a just heartbreaking powerful
beautiful in its artistry and in the way
you'd put such suffering is just
astounding and you yourself went to
prison and tortured and I guess my
question to you is how do you balance
telling you need to tell the story with
the danger that you're in because you
put yourself in such a danger to make
this thank you for being here we have a
same like fighting actually when when
you saw the truth and you know this is
the truth if you put it in 24 frames
it's gonna change that what I believe
that wow I grow up I grew up in
environment if you say no you can I go
to the jail or you're gonna killed and
and for us in in in Syria the films is
his art it's not a business it's a way
for freedom of exhibitions way for
changing way for saying no in
in many layers way and we know when we
saw the the the war light and involving
different Bart bar parties in in Syria
we couldn't do anything so we don't have
anything to do to fight or to to protect
ourselves or protect the truth that we
saw or the witnesses and evidence and
and and I feel like my duty my
responsibility to to do something
change from in my countries with with
with my my team of cinematographer that
we just put the camera and witnesses and
bring this is pictures in front of the
people to involve them engagement in in
in what's going on because the
politicians didn't do anything for seven
years it's it's it's a shame a big shame
that's mean you have to motivate the
people that will have the power of the
of them of the speech the the power of
of their voices to change this the
society around them and and it's not
also about us about this is volunteer
who is in the frontline they have their
finger their hand to do something and I
believe in the art as a way like to
change the society and that what we did
and when we see cream this is film which
Inge a lot of mind we change people
coming to us we say like we love Syrians
we never thought the Syrian like this it
changing the way of thinking about the
Syrian changing the way of thinking
about the society changing the way about
about also the truth that told by
Russians or by by Assad regime the
buriganga and we were just bringing that
with the evidence without paperwork that
the Russian they do through the social
media or through a different way we
bring it individuals and put it in front
the people and bring the people to be
with us in this is battles and yeah we
can't win
[Applause]
what what has been another question what
has been the reaction of the Russian
government
since you got nominated for an Oscar
they were very happy the Russian
government it's not work directly to me
because they know I'm a Syrian citizen
and they have a Syrian passport so they
they use the the Syrian regime to put
pressure over us and they run their
their media through the Syrian regime on
their media and to to destroy the trust
between between us and between the
people's like they accuse us as it's
like I'm a tourism director here like
watch out like maybe I put any explosion
pump under the the chairs like this way
and and and that this attack it's kept
going going through through like this is
which which is called the Russian
electronic army and the Syrian regime
electronic army there is in Samba trees
pork and there is in in Damascus and
they run this is there is a propaganda
machine through destroy the film's
bringing different disparate picture and
put it next to each other every comment
even the journalists there right about
the film's they just like publish on all
over that I mean the many of which are
not easy said it's it's out of us we are
just a review of film writers why we
should be in these battles and I feel
like in a way like an guilty in and this
is and it's I found that it's bigger
than me bigger than me as a filmmaker
who is trying to bring evidence about
war crimes and about people be killed
and about what what I've been witnesses
and they're finding in myself and bigger
battle then I can't handle it
because I'm I'm small enough to jail
[Laughter]
but you're a big artist yes sorry there
is a producer who's on your team who's
not here can you just tell us what what
his status is and what yeah
Kareem I beat the Syrian producer of the
film from Aleppo Media Center he just
got his visa yesterday yeah so he will
be arriving tomorrow tomorrow evening
hopefully if yeah hopefully if ban from
the immigration is moved from Department
of State Department to immigration now
yeah but we cross our fingers and and
hope for the best not optimistic I'm
always optimistic you are Danish I'm
Syrian how do you protect these guys as
the producer they're in grave danger and
I don't know if you were on the ground
there but how do you protect these guys
it's a it's a very difficult question
it's a very difficult question because
I'm from Denmark and in my role and the
film has been to - you know - to get
financed and and and pave the way for
the film and and it's sometimes very
very difficult to to get into these very
complex things that are going on
politically and and media-wise with all
these guys but of course we we we talk
and we we communicate and we I try to
understand what is going on and I try to
understand what we can do
to help them can see so this I has been
a long journey for you making this film
many many many many many years and so
[Music]
too many too many tell me how the film
changed over that journey and how you
ended up with this very intimate and
powerful portrait of your family you
know at the beginning of the process of
making strong Ireland i I I didn't want
myself in the film I didn't want any
white people in the film I didn't want
my sister in the film I had all these
rules about who was and wasn't going to
be allowed you know into the space to
help to tell the story and I also was
asking the question of what happened
right and the the question of what
happened this really easily arrived at
its a historical one you know a white
person killed a black person that black
person happened to be my brother and he
claimed to have done so in self-defense
and as is the course of proceedings in
this country grand jury declined to
indict him which meant that he didn't
stand trial at all it's not guilty or
innocent it's no crime has been
committed here and that person went home
to his life and my family went back into
our community did what they could to try
to advocate for justice and agitate for
justice after the no Tribunal came back
we you know in 1910 you to my parents
exhausted all of their you know their
their resources and you know the its it
was just sort of over and then what
happened after that was
the aftermath of this you know lack of
due process of this lack of the ability
to hold anyone accountable for my death
before my brother's death rather other
than my brother so the film really
turned you know from what happened to
why did it happened and what happened
afterward and you know the the process
of making the film involving other
people was about 10 years the process of
making the film you know personally and
sort of getting myself to the point of
shooting my first you know ptoo camera
with shitty sound and the you know the
doors open and my mom at the kitchen
table really like framed poorly and over
my shoulder that was you know that was
more than 10 years but what when I
eventually got to was a different line
of inquiry a line of inquiry that that
broadened story out from one that was
about my family to one that was about a
familiar sequence of events that
happened to particular people in the
United States and my family being just
the the vehicle through which we explore
this narrative of a racialized fear and
quote/unquote justifiable homicide
[Applause]
Jocelin I couldn't think of a more
perfect person to come in and help can't
see through this process you are known
for working with filmmakers of color and
telling difficult stories how did you
help shape the story you aunty invited
me into the film firstly as a friend I
think he had been working on the film
really for years and and two years
really thinking it through and
researching it before that but and then
I came on as an executive producer to
help with the financing when you ran
into financial trouble and then
ultimately as they asked me to take over
the production and we we talked a lot
about the importance of firstly removing
the burden of producing from Yancey
because there was so much pressure and
it was already so difficult to carry
this story for such a long time but then
you know over the course of talking with
Nancy about the project I realized that
the film that he was making was not
actually the film that he wanted and
that was a scary moment to be at a place
where your financing even making a film
for four years your financing is
starting to go and you have an edit
after hundreds and hundreds of hours of
shooting you have an edit that you
really aren't happy with and we
discussed that you know that that the
film was really sitting in the house of
grief and that there was nowhere to go
from that grief and as compelling as
Nancy's mother is Barbara is so
compelling you could watch Barbara Ford
for you know days and never get tired of
watching Barbara Ford but this spine of
the story had to change if we were going
to find a way through grief into
something deeper and
at the time Yancy's editor was moving on
to another project and I had been
working in Denmark with Sina Sorensen
the co-producer who's actually here
tonight and we talked about an editor
and a Muniz Velasco Henson who's also
here tonight who's a great editor and we
were very fortunate that he was
available and so we moved the Edit from
the US where killings were happening you
know every few days and we moved to
Denmark and Yancey reserved for nine
months I was there off and on during
that time for maybe I don't know a total
of five months and we all together as a
team led by ANSI working with Eunice we
all together as a team you know thought
through this investigation thought
through that the questions and changed
the questions that you wanted to ask and
really started to get at this idea of
fear you know reasonable fear is what
underpin self-defense cases and who gets
to decide reasonable fear the question
that you posed in the film what is the
distance of reasonable fear and then
really flipping that question to look at
whose fear is is actually reasonable in
America and if you were to do a body
count historically the weight of that
question is enormous ly significant and
that that whole process I think was was
a collaborative effort and I think you
wouldn't have come to it if you hadn't
come to all you know come through all
those years of working on the film and
sometimes the film takes as long as it
needs to take but it was a great process
and and I think we together tried to
bring out the best in the creative team
we were aided by great composers great
sound mixers and Alan Jacobson our DP is
here tonight and Alan Janna Cena all of
them are here thank you for all good
[Applause]
we're almost out of time so I'm gonna do
what I'm calling a Oscar lightning round
so because you know last year I was
honoured enough to sit on this stage and
the journey that you take from
nomination to Sunday is it's exciting
but it's also an exhausting and heroine
so I want to switch I just want to talk
to each of you about your experiences
but I'm gonna start with you Julie
because last year we were sitting we
were sitting on the stage and then I'm a
few days later we were in a spa
and after this sort of we haven't gotten
any spas this long ride we're sitting
there in this spot we were wiped out we
were exhausted and Julie turns to me and
she said I never want to do this again
really you've never told us that here
you are the six second consecutive year
and the only other person to be
nominated and documentary a feature for
two years in a row was what made dots or
questions good comment quick no I mean
are you talking about that when we were
in Miami it wasn't here don't worry was
actually we can we can all try to go
screen at that festival which has we
snuck into the spa which they didn't
want to let us into and it was empty
because it had just opened and yes it
was like that moment of this was it is
such a strange and surreal thing to do
this because the truth is in this
community we all really we grow to care
and
and love each other's films and we
support each other and so there's this
kind of wonderful it's part of the
experience that's unlike anything else
but it's also incredibly rigorous and
sometimes feels like the antithesis to
what you should be doing when you're in
the documentary world it's an
interesting combination Steve this is
your first nomination after many snubs
and how did it for editing I know you
were not afraid but your first
nomination as a director tell me how
that feels
well I'm hoping to crush all these
people here that's not true at all it
feels great
I'm trying to get a stand-up career it
it feels great
you know I feel like I've been I've had
plenty of good fortune over the years as
a filmmaker and this was not something
that happened but now that it's happened
it's it's it's very sweet it's wonderful
it's it's been great to sort of share
this ride with these two folks and it's
also been amazing to share it with the
son family because they're sick of us by
now but this has been a long sweet ride
with them and we couldn't do it with
Mark II responsible for Steve's first
nominee should take complete credit no I
think look it was important to think
about how this film could possibly get
Steven nomination and I've never really
said this in public and viewers here and
she now as I said when we started to
make the film that I think that there is
actually a shot that we would be
nominated for the Academy Award so it's
maybe ballsy but that was I really
believed in the story I believed in the
songs
and to the to the great so you are 89
and you are the oldest
I know I shouldn't give a say woman's
age but it's well documented and you are
the oldest
nominee in history I recently learned
that James ivory who is nominated a
screenplay is two weeks younger than me
and so Brian if you win the Oscar tell
me what joke you're gonna say on stage
yeah
were we and my team were to win the
Oscar that would be just an astounding
moment for Gregory and I couldn't be
more honored to really accept that award
on his behalf so but yeah I don't think
i'll be telling any jokes I think I'll
be telling telling the world to wake up
to what is going on in our country and
for any of those who believe that Russia
is not interfering in our democratic
process I'm gonna them to watch Icarus
dan you're married to of the famous
documentary filmmaker Liz Garbus did you
ever hear all those dreams think that
you could the easiest answer is no
definitely not you know I think my wife
is the best filmmaker in the world and
I've learned an enormous amount from her
from not just about filmmaking but
particularly in producing about learning
what a great filmmaker needs to succeed
learning about the kind of support they
need to get that a blessed best place
they can be with their film and so I
think I've benefited enormously from
from what a great storyteller she isn't
what a great partner she is because I've
learned how to support that person and
hopefully I've been able to do that for
Brian I'm able to do that for other
filmmakers so that's that's what I've
realized in this process and I'm happy
to say she's been nominated twice and I
wish her many more so she's winning as
far as I'm concerned Ferris
tell me what was your reaction when you
heard you were nominated tell me that
story because I've read it yeah that
wasn't that was where all this is
superpower decision maker and that was
the only one Syrian normally Bashar
Allah said go there and his brother
sister family like the Syria is a farm
of him so and I was like feeling like
jet lag and mixing in the time
and in in in almost in debate and I want
to sleep because I'm very tired and
Trump coming and they closing that the
road and I'm very upset because there
was before days like was McCarron or
decision-makers and yeah and I get a
call from the phone the hotel phones and
the friend of mine told me like why you
didn't answer on your mobile when I say
it like I'm I'm tired I'm gonna sleep I
told me like you get nominated it just
look to you he didn't say like that is
it I said yeah okay don't joke about
this he said like I'm not joking just
take take this is film and make drama
now to watch it and I was just like my
mobile phone it's because there is a
thousand of pictures so stuck with a lot
of this is a lot a lot of people
especially Syrian was like something so
beautiful like you only see like the
Syrian celebration celebrate because
this is moment because all of this sad
if if if this and we just reading death
death on our iPhones and and and our our
social media so I open my computer I
watch that all of that was very
difficult and yeah I mean crying from
inside without voice it was I don't know
I just like feeling like the your blood
like like a justice moving in your body
and you feel you're gonna when I was
torture in the prisons I couldn't say no
I don't like Assad and I can't say any
one of that question that asking me and
even I can't say any words and I feel
like I can say
a lot a lot and this is place with mrs.
films not just for me as a historian
director but also about thousand of
hundred I'm not gonna say like how them
too because the Russian would say that
one
okay hundred of filmmaker artists Syrian
and necessary and trying to bring with
his truth to this platform and most of
them killed and we are doing nothing and
I manage I'm lucky actually so what is
it gonna mean for Syria do you think if
anything if this film wins an Oscar
oh I think it's gonna mean that there
will be a lot more even more attention
than already already made and I hope
that all this attention will make make
some people think a little more about
what is the what is what is it like to
be a human being in this situation in a
conflict in a violent conflict how do
you deal with with your dilemmas as a
human being when you're when the bombs
are raining from the sky and and if if
we win
I hope that even more people will will
get the chance to to reflect a bit on
that stopping the war in Syria the rest
I mean using the art to stop the war
just imagine that this is film stop the
war it's big yet see you're the first
transgender nominee and what does that
mean what does that mean to so many
people that's incredible yeah
[Laughter]
being the first open standard is
obviously it's it's it's a rule that I
am grateful to occupy I certainly you
know didn't have to be the first I could
have you know I share that all sorts of
and you know I sort of think about it in
two ways I think about when I was young
and watching the Oscars night and when I
was grappling with what it meant to have
a gender identity right and I know that
on Sunday when you know when we I'm not
sure how many kids will be watching it
like but you know when we walk the red
carpet it will mean something to kids
you know around the world to see me and
to have that little like you know tag
first-gen trans nominee as a director
and that's great
and I'm glad for that but for the adults
in the world right I take that moment of
this first listen you know this moment
in history
I use it to hook people's attention back
onto the issue and turn it right back
around
because the kids need examples the
adults need to engage in these issues
because we are the ones who have created
this historical mess we are the ones who
have not yet reconciled with this
historical mess in this country so I
will wear you know a pin that kids can
see and point to and look and know that
you know one day that you'll be alright
or it will be okay but my attention will
be on the conversation that has to have
but it has to happen between you know
the adults that make policy in this
country and the the people who for for
far too long have lived with the
illusion that our criminal justice
system is equal for all because it is
not so yeah that that moment will be
special for me but but it's also a
moment that I will use to focus like a
laser beam on this thing that we have
yet to reconcile as as Angela Davis said
in San Francisco since the since the
aftermath of the Civil War being in at
the first half of the 21st century we
are still grappling with the issues that
we should have solved in the aftermath
of slavery so that's what the moment
means for me and it also you know it
means just being able to have the team
here right to have our Danish
counterparts here to have our DP here to
have my partner here to have Jos here
you know so many people spent so many
years like helping this phone picking me
up propping me up and keeping me going
that's some day no matter what happens
we'll will feel like an opportunity for
me to give the ultimate thank you to two
people who you know I've been able to
say thank you too but I haven't been
able to actually show
thank you on a ground world stage and
I'm just really grateful Jocelyn you get
the last word the you know people often
dismiss the Oscars you know fashion and
clothes and frivolous but what does it
mean
what will it mean to you to walk down
that red carpet with the ANSI to stand
there if you win what does that mean to
you and the work you've put into this
film and that you are representing this
particular filmmaker sitting next to you
well I think what he said firstly you
know it's a it's a strange thing to work
on films that have such gravity and to
being such a such an incredibly
difficult moment as a country to be
living with this administration and to
be living in such tyrannical times and
to be then engaged in walking down a red
carpet and having you know a lot of
people just say as their immediate
reaction who are you wearing you know
it's a it's a weird balance of things
and I think that it's the importance of
our industry and maintaining the
independence retaining the final cut for
artists championing the community as a
community and not being divided and not
going through a process that actually
further divides us and that becomes
controlled by money is really essential
so I would just say that in the larger
context of this political moment that we
should really mean
that solidarity because in solidarity
really isn't enough but it's a really
good starting point for each of us to
recognize ourselves in each other and I
would just advocate actually that the
Academy expand the documentary category
I think there should be an international
documentary category I think there
should be an editor award in other words
because documentary is incredibly
important and has become ever more
important and so I'll just take this
moment to advocate for that because I
know it makes everyone so damn
uncomfortable but as for walking down
the red carpet with mr. Yancey Ford it
has been a singular privilege to work
with the ancy Ford and this entire team
and I thank you for inviting me to
produce your film and I think I think
Barbara Ford for guiding us the whole
way and I think my partner
Anita whose shoulders I understanding on
and yeah thanks
[Applause]
well you know I know it's a cliche to
say but you're all winners and you've
all made extraordinary pieces of art
that will live forever and that will
inspire all of us forever so
congratulations and thank you for the
work you've done and I can't wait to see
you all out there on Sunday so thank you
and thank you guys
[Applause]
you